en grève mais toujours méchant
[Applaudissements]
s
la semaine de Stéphane Guillon
[Applaudissements]
à toi mon petit
vous allez être déçu Thierry
ouais je suis en grève comique est un
métier pénible sans aucun répit quand
vous êtes comique il faut l'être tout le
temps comique en vacances comique à la
plage comique au ski grand comique
polonais comique au ski
je suis encore
plusieurs fédérations défilent demain
notamment la FRG fédération du rire gras
présidé par Jean-Marie Bigard un slip
kangourou géant flottera en tête de
cortège
des actions très dures Charlotte de
Turckheim a menacé de se défaitestrer et
puis comme tout le monde s'en foutait
elle a renoncé
attention le mouvement pourrait
s'amplifier avec une journée Arthur que
des blagues à deux balles mais
rassurez-vous nous n'en sommes pas là
alors
on démarre service minimum Thierry
politique comment Fillon résiste titre
le JDD très dépressif le Premier
ministre travaille désormais en pyjama
réunion du MoDem quand Byro fait un
discours même c'est plus proche
collaborateur s'emmerde
anniversaire pour le 11 novembre des
lycéens ont lu des lettres de poilus
lettre particulièrement rasante voilà
[Applaudissements]
lettre de poilus extrait quand j'ai
perdu face aux Anglais j'ai chialé comme
une gonzesse Sébastien Chabal notre plus
grand poilu contemporain
social pendant la grève Robert Hossein
fait des prix pour son spectacle n'ayez
pas peur après 8h d'embouteillage se
faire cire 3 heures sur la vie du pape
n'ayez vraiment pas peur
texte Alain Decaux mise en scène aux
scènes il y a pas eu de canicule l'été
dernier voilà le résultat
mais toujours méchant
[Applaudissements]
d'après une étude de la SPA les chiens
martyrisés morde méfiez-vous dolga
Drucker entre les séances de photos
débiles et l'obligation d'assister à
Vivement Dimanche
ne laissez pas un bébé seul devant le
domicile de Michel
Patrick Bruel présidera à l'élection
Miss France 2008 après une rupture
président concours de Miss le meilleur
moyen pour pécho
le violeur des beaux quartiers frappait
chez Jeanne Moreau comme Aurélie Coluche
commissaire Jeanne Moreau
ce soir Nikos Aliagas star de la chanson
en Grèce alors je rappelle que la Grèce
a été ravagée par des incendies un pays
qui adulte Nikos est en état de choc on
pense très fort à eux
voilà
terminons avec un sourire dans ces
périodes de tension sociale il y a aussi
des gestes de solidarité
mal logé l'Élysée intervient pour que le
fils Tapie garde son appartement
chômage François Pinot trouve un boulot
à Claude Chirac
sacrifice l'épreuve de la rue pour
Valérie Pécresse c'est à pied que la
ministre traverse Versailles pour
acheter ses bananes en revanche Arnaud
Lagardère se sent seul ne laissons
personne au bord de la route soyez
généreux camarades aimez votre président
quoi qu'il fasse regardez cette photo
c'est vrai que ce soldat a souffert mais
il repart avec un souvenir à mettre sur
sa table de nuit bouche comme Sarkozy
récompense le mérite ensemble nous
vaincrons
ces hommes et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de innarditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu